rebuilding cost after three major
hurricanes in the United States and
Caribbean could reach hundreds of
billions of dollars harvey drenched
coastal Texas on August 25th hurricane
Irma made landfall in the Florida Keys
on September 10th and 10 days later
Hurricane Maria slammed into Puerto Rico
the impact of the storms could linger
for years and affect tourism and local
economy CBS News travel editor Peter
Greenberg is here with what travelers
need to know good morning good morning
so what's what should we know well in
the long term it's gonna be worse than
you think because travel and tourism is
the largest industry in the world more
or less its 11 percent of global GDP so
that's an average but in these
territories and districts and stin
island nations it's much higher than
that the US Travel Association around
the numbers in Puerto Rico alone a 50%
drop in tourism or no more than five
billion dollars less in travel or spend
but even more important 36,000 jobs lost
that's a 50% drop it's gonna be a
hundred so and that means over a
two-year period that's revenue they'll
never recoup so what options do people
havin sorry about your voice you thank
you
it's it doesn't hurt you though you just
lost it okay so a lot of people have
Thanksgiving plans you're planning to go
to one of these areas what are the
options do you get your money back can
you go someplace else in the area and
not get gouged well the answer the first
question is you can more or less get
your money back if you pay with a credit
card because you did not receive the
good or service that you contracted for
but if you bought travel insurance you
had to buy it before the storm was
actually named that's a very difficult
determination but you have to do that
the real problem for your second
question is law supply and demand as
people realize now they're not going to
go to those destinations like st.
Maarten say Thomas st. John Puerto Rico
they're gonna look to the places outside
the hurricane belt Grenada Aruba curaçao
Jamaica Barbados and the numbers are
going to change airlines have capped
their fees to the affected areas they
have not capped their fees to those
areas that were not affected which means
air fares are going up hotel fares are
going up and
factor in this jet fuel prices are up
50% since June so I'm not going to be
surprised if they add a fuel surcharge
on to the deal as well thanks Peter
no cost us more in the long run thank
you Peter if you feel better I will